je perds 2 est le commandeur de la
goélette thalassa que l'idée vous faites
vous de laventure bon je crois que l'
aventure c'est enfin moi je vois pas du
tout comme ça l' aventure pour moi
l'aventuré c'est quelque chose de
personnel et d'intérieur bon si vous
avez la capacité d'être un peu aller
coûte si vous avez la capacité de
d'écouter un petit peu les autres de les
regarder de d'essayer de vivre un peu
avec eux vous vous pouvez vivre une
aventure mais je pense que le mot a été
très très employé d'élever des il n'y
aurait pas galvauder même un peu un peu
on a un peu fait maigrir son ampleur moi
je crois que c'est quand même quelque
chose d'abord d'intérieur et de
personnel je pense que leur aventure on
la lit d'abord dans les livres parce que
dans le livre c'est vous qui faites le
décor c'est l'auteure qui vous fait
l'histoire alors dans ce petit reportage
vous n'avez pas rencontré dit que la
hulot tout cela parce qu'il est très
loin en soutenant ou surya et c c'est un
peu votre environnement je ne le pense
pas mais enfin
non c'est pas du tout les mêmes optiques
unis que l'on se connaît depuis
longtemps je crois qu'il fait comme un
des émissions qui sont très belles et
très très bien ciblé mais c'est pas du
tout la même optique disons que nicolas
essaie de faire des choses
spectaculaires
je crois qu'il a examiné d'abord en
avant ce côté là et tous les
réalisateurs qui travaillent avec lui le
savent bien
nous c'est un petit peu différent
d'abord nos émissions sont fabriqués
entièrement par des équipe
journalistique qui vont plutôt aller à
la rencontre des gens essayer de
travailler un petit peu autour des
personnages avouez quand même georges
perd 2 que vous avez le monopole de la
mer au bras devant même son genre le
monopole et si d'ailleurs aux touches à
ce monopole ou bondi ces noms sont les
issues sont les anglais qui ont le
monopole de la mer ligure la télévision
bon c'est vrai on a démarré
nous on dit ça aujourd'hui mais il ya il
ya 18 ans on a démarré ce petit magazine
tranquillement qui s'appelait au départ
un petit magazine de loisirs
et puis petit à petit à force de
rencontres à force d'habitude
bon ben on a réussi à le créer ce que ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'on n'a jamais embauché des marins
pour faire de la télévision nous on a
toujours embaucher des journalistes pour
s'intéresser à la mer ce qui fait qu
eux-mêmes sont les premiers
téléspectateurs maritime et les bars à
ceux-là aussi bien sûr isabelle je sais
bien sûr mais ce que je veux dire ce
qu'il veut il faut pas mélanger métier
nous ne sommes pas des marins
vous avez analysé les vrais réseaux du
succès de dallas a hobo pense qu'on a
les meilleurs ça c'est évident qu'en
dehors de cela c'est des meilleurs au
début c'était difficile dont je crois
que c'est parce que le la voile open ce
qu'on appelle la voix l'open les grandes
aventures maritimes sont sont nés en
france à partir de 64 avec tabarly
nous on est arrivés en 76 et c'était les
débuts c'était toute cette famille louis
caradec
tous ces gens là qui ont fait démarrer
la voile open qui était d'abord une
voile ce spectacle c'est à dire en
général un homme seul contre l'océan
c'est ce qui a fait démarrer la voile en
france mais à cette époque là la voile
était considérée non pas comme un sport
mais comme une aventure humaine mais
depuis 89 vous êtes à 20h40 un avenir
aujourd'hui nature 50 puisque ce sont
les nouveaux horaires du début de la
soirée
ça n'était pas de paris gagné dès le
départ il fallait le gagner
non ce jeu propose d'abord quand j'écris
est un massage ne pensait pas que ça
durerait aussi longtemps
c'était pour moi une à une récréation un
plaisir parce qu'ils se trompent j'ai
fait pas mal de voile mais c'est tout je
bouge on sait pas que ça durerait autant
alors le fait d'être passé à 20h50
c'est un petit inconvénient quand même
en ces termes là c'est qu'on devient de
plus en plus sélectif est de plus en
plus durs entre nous-mêmes enfin toute
l'équipe de rédaction
c'est vrai qu'on devient de plus en plus
dur au niveau du travail les convoque
les choses soient de plus en plus fini
alors évidemment ça demande encore plus
de travail l'autre initiaux qui vient
d'ailleurs immédiatement après thalassa
le vendredi c'est faut pas rêver il a
encore une et une émission qui a fait à
peu près toutes les cases de la grille
d'une chaîne de télévision
en en particulier france rond et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui cette émission s'est
installé s'est installé derrière
je pensais pas personnellement que
c'était une bonne place parce que moi je
me disais les téléspectateurs resteront
peut-être pas deux heures dans le même
style puisque c'est quand même c'est la
même famille c'est les mêmes équipes qui
fabrique ça tout cela vienne la qualité
des reportages
oui je crois que cela les gens qui
savent et nous on n'impose jamais un
reportage nous on estime que dans une
équipe journalistique où le journaliste
a envie de faire un reportage et l'envi
c'est déjà un bénéfice pour la réussite
si quelqu'un n'a pas envie de faire un
reportage je crois qu'il faut pas les
forcer alors il pourrait peut-être il y
avoir repéré un jour c'est que vous êtes
entré dans une spécialité et vous n'en
sortez pas alors vous avez envie
vraiment pendant toute votre existence
de consacrer aux travaux de la mer moi
je ne sais pas bon d'abord avec faut pas
rêver on a on a élargi le vin vera est
large et la réflexion
je crois que en matière de télévision ce
comme dans tous les métiers
si demain je m'emmerde il faut chasse
aux deux choses le temps je m'amuse je
continue à leur bojan merci
[Musique]